50 plus fascinating language facts you
didn't know
the world is full of diverse and unique
languages from the exotic sounds of
japanese to the romantic expressions of
french
how all of these language originated is
often debated
ideas such as the bow wow theory say
that language began with humans
imitating the sounds animals make to
communicate others believe that language
was a divine gift but most agree that
all languages develop from a single
language into the thousands we have
today
how much do you know about foreign
languages whether you're a student
learning a second language a polyglot or
a translator check out the infographic
there are dozens of interesting language
facts on this list that will inspire you
let's look at 50 of them that will
fascinate you
1.
there are over 7 000 languages worldwide
and most of them are dialects
the bible is the most translated book
followed by pinocchio the english word
alphabet comes from the first two
letters of the greek alphabet alpha and
beta
five
two thousand four hundred of the world's
languages are in danger of becoming
extinct and about one language becomes
extinct every two weeks the first
printed book was in german
there are over 200 artificial languages
in books movies and tv shows such as
klingon
8. the popcorn language of rotokas only
has 11 letters making it the smaller
alphabet
nine
only 23 languages account for more than
half of the world's population
10. about two-thirds of all languages
are from asia and africa
11. french is the main foreign language
taught in the uk
twelve of all the language facts this
one fascinates us the most
17. the florentine dialect was chosen as
the national language of italy most
regions in italy primarily speak their
own dialect to this day
kinshasa is the world's second largest
french-speaking city after paris
kinshasa is the capital city in congo
there are about 24 official languages
spoken throughout europe
other than english french is the only
language taught in every country
on average people only use a few hundred
words in daily conversation while most
languages have 50 000 plus words
german words can have three genders
masculine feminine and neutral
the united states has no official
language most people just assume it's
english
the language of la gomera spoken of the
coast of spain consists entirely of
whistles
but what if you can whistle
over twenty thousand new french words
are created each year
about thirty percent of english words
come from french
botswana has a language made up of five
primary click sounds
spanish contains about four thousand
arabic words
german is the most spoken language in
europe four countries have it as their
official language
physical contact during a conversation
is completely normal when speaking
spanish
papua new guinea has the most languages
840.
italian is a minority language in brazil
over 300 languages are spoken in london
alone no matter what you have a pretty
good chance of finding someone to speak
with
the languages spoken in north korea and
south korea are different they have
distinct vocabularies and grammatical
rules due to being separated for so long
the english language contains the most
words with over
250 000 words
spanish is the second most spoken
language in the world
multiple studies have shown that
learning a second language can improve
the memory and slow the process of aging
this is one of our favorite language
facts
[Music]
argentina still has a high number of
welsh speakers
due to settlers inhabiting the patagonia
mountains hundreds of years ago
russian was the first language spoken in
outer space
people who speak chinese use both sides
of the brain whereas english only uses
the left side
21 countries of spanish as their
official language making it a great
choice for travelers
hindi didn't become the official
language of india until 1965.
the pope tweets in nine languages but
his spanish account has the most
followers
hawaiians have over 200 different words
for rain
the culinary and ballet worlds use
mostly french words and terms
in indonesian air means water
japanese uses three different writing
systems kanji katakana and hiragana
the u.s has the second highest number of
spanish speakers after mexico
mandarin chinese is the most spoken
language in the world if you speak it
you can speak to 13 of the world's
population
cryptophasia is a language phenomenon
that only twins identical or fraternal
can understand
thank you for watching if you liked our
video please like comment and subscribe
to our channel
for more similar content
you